extreme weather is also behind wrenching
scenes of devastation in europe
on a scale we are only just beginning to
understand
more than 180 people have been killed
due to record amounts of rain mostly in
germany
chris livesay is in the hard-hit avaya
region chris good morning to you
good morning this is one of the many
bridges that could not withstand these
crushing floods that have killed
more than 100 people here in the arvila
region alone
not something you expect in a country
with such advanced infrastructure
and warning systems
after days of swelling rivers now
swelling death tolls as bridges
homes even swathes of villages vanished
no not in a beleaguered developing
nation but across europe's economic
powerhouses
like in the tiny german town of insul
did you ever imagine something like this
happening here in germany
well i think not of this magnitude not
of this size
i don't think anyone has imagined or
could have imagined
something like this the devastation so
shocking german chancellor angela merkel
struggled to explain it
i can almost say that the german
language doesn't have the words for the
destruction she said
billions will be needed to rebuild in
germany alone
some towns are likely gone for good
though both climate scientists
and the german chancellor warn extreme
weather events are
bound to return
one flood isn't an example of climate
change said merkel
but if we look at the last events of
recent years
decades then they are simply more
frequent than they were previously
so we must make an effort a great effort
mother nature rearing her head but
climate change
pushing her hand
now to make matters worse many of these
communities had been hit hard
by covid hotels restaurants that had
long been closed were only just getting
back up on their feet
now many of them are washed away anthony
chris livesay in germany thank you chris